bartenders lift your lid seeker
ingredient is sweet potatoes I'm just
like how do I bring out sweet potato the
country's top bartenders converged on
Las Vegas to battle it out the game
create a signature cocktail using a
secret ingredient to be presented to our
esteemed panel of judges all before time
runs out whoo we have three premier
bartend it's all competing for one place
in the grand fire
that's me our bartenders my name is
Julian Kay I am from Las Vegas
representing Vegas as a craft cocktail
competition makes it even more exciting
my name is Rand Juan and I'm from Boston
Massachusetts I really like bartending
because it's kind of like cooking the
better ingredients you use the better
the outcome my name is Vincenzo Ben
Jamie
I'm originally from Italy but I live in
Europe for the past four years my style
of bartender is pretty much European I
like Japanese bartender like American
bartender so I try to incorporate all of
them in just one style welcome
bartenders under the lids in front of
you is a secret ingredient with that
secret ingredient you have to make an
unforgettable gin cocktail our winner
will move on with a chance to be crowned
America's bartender it's time to reveal
the secret ingredient I was amped I was
reading my journal was going it's my
opening I want to open there I know what
it is bartenders lift your lid secret
ingredient is sweet potato okay how do I
bring out sweet potato your time starts
now the texture of these cocktails gonna
be really interesting you could very
easily be very grainy very true but I'd
like to see where these guys are gonna
go with it I knew that
how to do cut up the sweet potato give
the sweet potato in the eyesight charger
give this cherry in there and just let
that sit I was going to take the longest
being so it's boiled I need to bring out
something to have that flavor come out
you know it's really interesting as
sweet potatoes so simple but it's really
so complex you have to decide on an
action plan and just stick with it
it's the aromatics that it's got a video
challenge it's one of things in a drink
where it's almost like you have to make
it into a juice or something's more
simple the caliber of these bartenders
that magnificent they're the best in the
country so we have to challenge the bar
absolutely they they know so many flavor
profiles and this is a chance for them
to really show us what they've memorized
over the years three minutes the guy
bartenders the time was going very fast
and you need to just speak it out the
clock scares me but everybody's shaking
everybody's working on their drinks
everything's coming together yeah not
messing around
that's one thing I noticed about this
round these guys they're like moving
it's good to see them working so well 30
seconds I worried a little about the
salt level because I want to make sure
you send the lifeline of the cocktail I
wish I could grab another spoon and like
this like tasted in or something like I
couldn't do that and that drove me
insane there was so much tension inside
me I mean and I could have handled that
nine eight seven six five four three two
one step away from your stations please
when the clock stopped I was just trying
to stay calm today look I didn't look so
frantic bartenders great job
Joo young when you tell the judges what
you've made today I made a cocktail
the name is home sweet home of course we
have Bombay Sapphire sweet potato I put
a little mustard seed clove for the
spice and playing on simple syrup a
little bit primitive for the fruit
flavor to bring out the little sweetness
and round it out like a sweet potato pie
but with salt the fragrance of the dill
took me to dill heaven it was magical I
felt I was a little
myself the clove this is where I thought
it kind of the clove just danced and it
kept dancing and just he actually went
to dancing to running to sprinting and
kind of just forgot everybody else ran
tell the judges about you a cocktail
my cocktail is called autumn and Wales I
went with our jet as well as great -
almonds on top to accentuate the almonds
add a touch of apricot cordial to there
just to give us some more bounce to
bring like I said the fall flavors the
winter flavors that really kind of round
it all out together and that was pretty
much my inspiration behind that give you
guys a little welcoming to the new
season coming up I think you know like
pumpkin those same spices worked very
well as sue potato on it obviously shows
really well here I wish there was a
little bit more of that sue potato
flavor but watching you infuse it in the
ice I was genius and I get the sherry
coming through as well so nicely done
thank you thank you just Vincenzo tell
us about your drink my drink is inspired
by Queen Victoria
it's called Victoria's nectar I add some
coriander some citrus part and my
sweetener was the apricot marmalade I
add also some rubber soda which was very
floral and martini granola so just a
little touch we were part with Sun
German and the sage I barely mother a
little bit it's going to separate the
drink with with the sweet potato density
I think balance wise on that drink it
probably just was a little bit too much
beautiful color beautiful texture I
really enjoyed that drink well done
pinch answer bartenders did a phenomenal
job
the winning drink today was the cocktail
that best highlighted the secret
ingredient with balanced beautiful
flavors texture and imagination and the
winner today going through to our grand
final with a chance to be crowned
America's bartender is
Rann bow down the congratulations other
rounds autumn in wales cocktail one
today because he's brilliant sweet
potato infusion highlight the secret
ingredient and was ultimately served
with a perfect bowman nice light texture
brands going freeze to the final
congratulations on that well done I'm
pretty happy but you know it's no time
to celebrate
still warm around I have a lot of
preparation to do tonight it's not over
yet
want to try making this winning cocktail
at home give it a taste for more
exciting competition subscribe to the
GPU channel